♪ ♪
>> I BELIEVE THE LEGACY AND
ANCESTRY OF BLACK AMERICANS AS
BEING INSULTED EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I WILL NOT PRETEND TO BE A
VICTIM IN THIS COUNTRY.
I KNOW THAT MAKES MANY PEOPLE ON
THE LEFT UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Laura: AND DEMOCRATS ON THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WERE
EXTREMELY UNCOMFORTABLE, AS
CANDACE OWENS JUST SLASHED AT
THE NARRATIVE OF THE PEOPLE LIKE
NADLER AND TED LIEU.
ONCE HE SPENT WEEDED OUT THE
VIDEO OF THE CONFRONTATION WITH
LIEU, IT RACKED UP 4.47 MILLION
VIEWS IN LESS THAN 24 HOURS.
A TWITTER RECORD FOR THAT
NETWORK THEY'RE JOINING ME NOW
IN HER FIRST INTERVIEW SINCE THE
EXPLOSIVE HEARING AS CANDACE
OWENS HERSELF.
SHE IS THE DIRECTOR FOR TURNING
POINT USA, AND LEO TO ROW, CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY.
BOTH SIDES REPRESENTED TONIGHT.
CANDACE, WHY DO YOU THINK YOUR
MOMENT, AND I WATCHED IT FROM
BEGINNING TO END, HAS DRAWN SUCH
ATTENTION, AND WHAT HAS BEEN THE
REACTION TO YOU PERSONALLY SINC
SINCE?
>> I THINK HE DREW ATTENTION FOR
A LOT OF REASONS.
IN MANY WAYS, PEOPLE ON THE
RIGHT FEEL VINDICATED.
I KNOW A LOT OF MODERATE PEOPLE
CAME OVER AND REALIZED THAT WHAT
I WAS TALKING ABOUT WERE
ACTUALLY REAL ISSUES IN BLACK
AMERICA.
I TOUCHED UPON THE LITERACY
RATES.
75% OF BLACK BOYS IN CALIFORNIA
NOT BEING ABLE TO READ IS A
PROBLEM IN BLACK AMERICA.
WHITE NATIONALISM, ONE BLACK ON
BLACK CRIME, 90.1% OF ALL
HOMICIDES AGAINST BLACK
AMERICANS ARE PERFORMED BY OTHER
BLACK AMERICANS.
THE ENTIRE HEARING, IN MY
OPINION, WAS A HOAX, HE
CONTINUED HOAX ON BLACK AMERICA,
WHICH COMES TO US FROM DEMOCRATS
WHO WANT US ULTIMATELY TO FAIL
BY FOCUSING ON SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT HARMING US.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE ARE FACING.
>> Laura: NOW, LEO, YOU
WATCHED, I'M SURE, AT LEAST PART
OF WHAT CANDACE SAID YESTERDAY.
YOUR REACTION?
>> RIGHT NOW, CANDACE OWENS IS
GETTING 15 MINUTES OF FAME, AND
GIVE ME 30 SECONDS TO PROVE MY
POINT.
SHE JUST AGAIN ASSUMED THAT ALL
DEMOCRATS ARE HOPING BLACK
PEOPLE FAIL.
ON HER INTERVIEW WITH C-SPAN,
SHE SAID THE WORD NATIONALISM
HAS BEEN COMPROMISED OR POISONED
BY ELITIST.
TELL MUCH OF THE PEOPLE IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
THEN SHE TRIED TO PUT YOURSELF
IN THE SAME CATEGORY OF
DONALD TRUMP, TALKING ABOUT THE
FALSE NARRATIVE.
BUT PROMOTING HER EMPLOYER AND
SAYING THAT SHE WENT TO
JERUSALEM, NOT A SINGLE DEMOCRAT
WENT THERE.
MISS OWENS, LET ME TELL YOU, 77%
OF JEWS IN AMERICA VOTED FOR --
AMERICANS ARE NOT STUPID.
I LISTEN TO EVERYTHING YOU JUST
SAID, AND YOU CAN CHALLENGE WHAT
I SET ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
BLACKS, THE NUMBER OF JEWS WHO
SUPPORT DEMOCRATS, BUT YOU DID A
GOOD JOB MARKETING YOURSELF
TODAY, PUTTING YOURSELF IN THE
SAME BOAT AS THE PRESIDENT
PAIRED GOOD JOB, CANDACE.
>> Laura: FOR THE RECORD --
>> THAT'S A PERSONAL ATTACK.
>> Laura: YOU ARE ATTACKING
HER CHARACTER.
>> I UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Laura: YOU ARE ATTACKING
HER CHARACTER AND WHAT SHE SAID.
>> IN MY OPINION --
>> Laura: HOLD ON, LET HER
SPEAK.
>> THAT WAS AN AD HOMINEM
ATTACK, AND I'M NOT GOING TO
PLAY THESE PLAYGROUND TACTICS
WITH YOU.
I'M GOING TO KEEP THE FOCUS ON
BLACK AMERICA AND THE THINGS
ACTUALLY IMPACTING US.
THIS IS AN ADULT CONVERSATION
THAT NEEDS TO BE HAD.
THE SHOOTINGS IN CHICAGO.
IT WAS LAURA INGRAHAM WHO HOSTED
AND HAD A REAL CONVERSATION WITH
PEOPLE THAT WERE LIVING IN THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD ABOUT THINGS
AFFECTING THEM.
ULTIMATELY, THIS IS WHY BLACKS
ARE LEAVING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BECAUSE
AD HOMINEM ATTACKS DO NOT MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL BETTER ABOUT
THEMSELVES.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO IMPACT OUR
SITUATION IN BLACK AMERICA.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE YOU
CONSIDER YOURSELF A CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADER.
YOU'RE JUST ATTACKING ME.
YOU HAVEN'T OFFERED ANYTHING --
>> NO AD HOMINEM ATTACKS.
DOES ANYONE WATCHING HER PROGRAM
HONESTLY BELIEVE WHAT SHE SAID?
SHE SAID DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
FAIL.
SEE, THOSE ARE TALKING POINTS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW DEEP DOWN
INSIDE JUST BECAUSE YOU DISAGREE
WITH THE DEMOCRATS, YOU CANNOT
ASSUME THAT DEMOCRATS WANT BLACK
PEOPLE TO FAIL.
THAT IS WHAT YOU JUST THAT ON
NATIONAL TV.
>> I DID, AND I BELIEVE THAT.
I CAN BACK THAT UP WITH FACTS.
>> THAT'S MY POINT, LAURA.
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY
SOMETHING -- I THINK A LOT OF
DEMOCRAT LEADERS ARE FREAKING
OUT AND TRIED TO KILL HER
YESTERDAY AND THAT HEARING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT WHAT SHE
IS SAYING TO TAKE HOLD IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
LEO, I HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT.
I KNOW CANDACE, AND WHAT WAS
THAT ABOUT HER --
>> YOU KNOW ME.
>> Laura: I DO, AND THAT IS
WHY I WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THESE
UNDERLYING ISSUES.
THAT IS WHY WE WENT TO CHICAGO
TO DO THAT FOR HIM.
THAT IS WHY WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
THE NEIGHBORS THAT ARE HURTING.
THEY ARE REALLY HURTING.
THEY ARE NOT HURTING BECAUSE OF
WHITE NATIONALISM.
THAT IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM.
>> HERE'S MY REQUEST, LAURA.
I WOULD LIKE TO GO TO CHICAGO
WITH YOU AND DEBATE MISS OWENS
ON THAT ISSUE.
I WOULD LOVE TO GO.
>> WHY DO WE NEED TO DEBATE?
>> BECAUSE I WANT TO DISCUSS --
>> WHY DO YOU WANT TO HEAR FROM
THE PEOPLE --
>> THE MOST DIVERSE PARTY --
>> Laura: HOLD ON, LEO --
>> LET ME SPEAK, LET ME SPEAK.
I HAVE NOT SET A SINGLE THING
ATTACKING YOUR CHARACTER.
I DON'T NEED TO PEERED I'M
CONFIDENT IN MY IDEAS.
I'M CONFIDENT IN THE FACT BLACK
AMERICA IS WAKING UP AND REALIZE
WE HAVE BEEN MISSING OUT.
I'M CONFIDENT THE BIGGEST ISSUE
FACING OUR COMMUNITY --
>> MS. OWENS --
>> I CUT YOU OFF, OKAY?
I HAVE NOT ATTACKED HE WANTS.
I'VE ATTACKED DEMOCRATS --
>> LET ME GET IN -- EVERY
DEMOCRAT.
SHE HAS BASICALLY SAID THAT
EVERY DEMOCRAT, THE MOST DIVERSE
PARTY WITH MINORITIES AND PEOPLE
O'CONNORS, SHE HAS BEEN ON
NATIONAL TV OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
DEMOCRATS WANT PEOPLE TO FAIL.
MS. OWENS, THAT IS NOT CORRECT.
THOSE ARE YOUR WORDS, THAT IS
NOT TRUE.
>> THAT IS A FACT.
>> Laura: I WOULD ACTUALLY
TAKE WHAT LEO SAYS WITH A
GREATER SENSE OF BELIEF AND
CREDIBILITY.
LEO, YOU SAID SOMETHING SIMILAR
EVERY TIME SOMEONE IMPARTS THE
WORST MOTIVE ON PEOPLE WHO
DISAGREE WITH THEM ON POLICY.
AND IT HAPPENS FAR TOO OFTEN.
THE WORST MOTIVES EVER COME ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
ARE YOU A WHITE PERSON?
THEN YOU HAVE TOO MUCH WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
YOU NEED TO SIT DOWN AND LET
SOMEONE ELSE'S TRUTH BE HEARD.
LEO, YOU GOT YOUR TRUTH OUT,
CANDACE GOT HER TRUTH OUT, AND I
THINK WE DO WANT THE
PROBLEM-SOLVING DONE ON BOTH
SIDES.
WE WANT PROBLEM-SOLVING ON THE
SHOW, AND THAT MEANS WE HAVE
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW.
THERE LEO, YOU CAN COME TO
CHICAGO.
CANDACE, WE CAN ROLL UP OUR